today's topic we're gonna be reacting to
a PewDiePie video that just came out if
you don't know what stoicism is don't
worry I didn't use have a clue either a
lot of self-help book today are based on
stoic practices but I have been
rebranded to fit the modern world so
even if you're not familiar with
stoicism there's still a good chance
that you practice it even without
knowing it for example things like
journaling meditating practice of
self-restraint are all in a way stoic
exercises so let's begin with its
origins because to fully understand and
engage with ideas we need to understand
where they came from I think that was so
Cretaceous I love the origin of stoicism
its foundation comes from its own name
which in Latin is slower I like Irish
saddle in Plato who had their famous
grandeur in schools so immense simply a
painted porch Epictetus describe what
the fundamentals of psoases amaze there
are things in life you can't control and
there are things that happen without our
control or beyond our control
according to Epictetus we should calmly
accept when things out of our control
happen but we as individuals can however
control our own actions through
self-discipline no that's the definition
I knew I didn't know its origins are in
the stuff I'll browse with you want to
pop through this video I didn't expect
all this information on philosophers oh
I know what it was a complicated word I
didn't know the definition of Stoicism
yeah but I mean I do it I guess that's
what I do yeah that's pretty much my way
of life I was just not putting a word on
it hmm
I was just like I'm with this can't
change it oh yes there's something you
could do about no you want to cry about
it because it won't feel better
you broke up with your boyfriend cry
listen the damn song get over it yeah I
didn't know that was the word for that
yeah stop being a was what I said I was
in the army and so that is the
definition of having to be stoic
basically you can't control most of your
day-to-day decisions so just focus on
when you can't control but even in my
personal life I'm like that that's why I
like this quarantine most of the stuff
around me when it's terrible if I can't
control it I'm not gonna stress it make
the most out of it and it's interesting
because I have conversations with people
and if they have a how you're not
bothered by this I'm like how can I stop
this I've lost 40 grand I've lost most
of my income how am I
get mad if can I control it can I stop
this epidemic I'm gonna be more mad
about like a mosquito in my house or in
my room when I'm trying to sleep
really I'm watching yeah so I'm gonna be
like no do you know what does get me
upset that I try to control a lot is
when I don't do the work I'm supposed to
do or when I know I could have done
better night don't that's when I get
upset could do something that's that's
the whole point so I only get annoyed
with things and I know I could have
control but even then I know it's not
good to be in order to be angry about it
so I control that emotion as well I
could get mad over things I cannot
control but it's like to me getting mad
it is a process it's part of the process
really it's okay to be ticked off bottom
why can't you bring some energy you know
I mean I use it the first manager I let
it out and I'm good it helps me move on
yeah but I'm not gonna dwell on it for
you know over and over and over maybe
when I'm gonna talk back about it like
you're what happened between you and
that person I'm gonna really relive
those emotions so of course I'm gonna
act and be a certain way just because I
that's how I am I relive stuff but I
think it's a professed to get over stuff
I get you I think I guess probably in
your day to day life that's probably not
a problem I think for me especially for
example in a crisis I have no time for
none of that when it's a crisis time I
don't care how stupid the decisions that
are being made my whole thing is what is
the most pragmatic solution let's get
through this I'm only thinking logically
because like you know I can't control my
emotions and it's necessary for me so us
so we can get to the best place possible
you know when they talk about keeping a
journal and writing it down this is me
keeping a journal and writing it down
people don't wait beige is okay today
it's your meditation if this is my
meditation I can see me walking like
this that's me I'm not mad at that all
right let's keep going with the jail I
used to study a fair bit of Buddhism and
what struck a chord in me was the idea
of reincarnation if you live a virtuous
life you will be rewarded in the next
but if there's no reincarnation then you
still lived a virtuous life Marcus had
the same sentiment but provided way more
eloquently here's another quote from his
meditations live
like if there are gods and they are just
then they will not care how devout you
have been but will welcome you based on
the virtues you have lived by if there
are gods but unjust then you should not
want to worship them if there are no
gods then you will be gone but when I've
lived a noble life that would live on in
the memories of their loved ones
this is crazy to read because this is
like the conclusion I came up to when I
was like 12 like growing up is like just
like a Muslim family I'm serious I'm
like I'm not about this so I'm not gonna
pretend and then some people would
always ask me is like AB aren't you
afraid of going to hell or like the
afterlife and I said listen I'm going to
just try to be a good person I'm gonna
try to do right by my neighbors and my
community and try to be the best person
I can be if there is a God he gonna know
right this is the father I said to
myself if God wants you to be a good
person and go - I don't think he's gonna
care whether or not you prayed them five
times a day or not I show up at the
doors I've been a good person you let me
in and if a God won't let you in just
because you didn't pray then that's
probably not somebody I wanted to
worship anyways that's how I felt so I
didn't poop other people's religion I
said to myself I'm gonna just do right
by people you feel me I'm like and I
remember I would have these
conversations and I remember I would
bring up that girl who grew up in a
Christian family she was like oh you're
gonna burn in Hellfire for the rest of
your life and I was like because I don't
know the word of God and she said that's
the way it is and I remember thinking to
myself but why those people who
literally lived in Amazon their whole
life and never heard your religion and
they deserved also you know that that's
probably not somebody I want to spend
the rest of my eternity with and you
probably haven't done anything wrong
no but come so to me just crying and
crazy to read this because this is a
conclusion I came up to when I was young
- just like Nietzsche said he was a
white to live for can bear almost any
how if you have a purpose you can live
through any pain and suffering the
purpose for the stoic is virtue and it
turns any pain on its head that's what
makes the assistance so powerful and
timeless that is still practiced today
memento mori
do not let it frighten you or remind you
to live life with virtue
memento mori by practicing so is ISM
there's no pain and suffering in this
world that you can't endure memento mori
nothing
can be taken from you for a stoic only
Valley's virtue I like that line nothing
could be taken from you for a stoic only
values virtue when we say boo boo if you
have values you can't be bought out
remember we talked about that quite a
few times where we said like oh all
these people love to talk about I have
this as a value this is a value money
becomes involved and someone threatens
that and all of a sudden they drop their
values for income you know and I'm like
but did you really have values or did
you have ideas that you like I don't
know for me this is like all interested
you see this written because these are
ideas I've always liked and it's cool to
see that these have been here for
thousands of years and it always brings
up to that same adage that like nothing
is new Under the Sun mental morning what
it means is really just like you will
die yes so just live your day how you
live your life how you should live your
life huh and just make the best out of
it angry right there's nothing you gonna
treat at the end of the day mm-hmm
remember you could die so don't be don't
be so yeah memento mori any suffering
and pain will be an opportunity for you
to display and practice your virtue
that's another idea I really like in
divorcing is that you don't have values
until they're tested it's easy to
believe in all these ideas super easy
but it's not until you have to sacrifice
for those virtues and I mean truly
sacrifice that they really become inked
in you as a person you know and and and
that's a hard thing for people to
understand if they haven't been through
it but there is something really
peaceful about knowing what your values
are because they've they've been put to
the test like I know what I will never
do I know in actions I will never engage
it because the fact that they've I've
been through it already so yeah you know
there's another one that I really liked
that's funny you know why because I
always tell people never seek out
comfort you know seek out a life of
suffering and difficulty because through
that suffering difficult you're gonna
find a sense of peace you're gonna find
a sense of who you are because you've
been through and you're gonna understand
what it means to be you you know because
Comfort anyone can pretend to be but
it's really when you're uncomfortable
that who you are gets really tested seek
out the struggle doesn't mean make
stupid decisions
but go hey sometimes there are stupid
decisions and you're gonna look at them
in hindsight but you have to be brave
you have to be brave and you have to
despite being afraid you have to have
that sense of life I'm gonna push
forward because in doing that you are
going to understand how you like to move
where you want to go but if you stand
still and you stay in your little
comfort zone that you've already
explored for hundreds of years
right hundreds you've noticed that over
for a long time so you know then you're
never going to be able to outgrow that
pasture and it's like a cow a cow has to
travel adventure to eat can't just stay
in the same circle yeah right right you
have to eventually expand on that so you
have to go to different areas and then
you know the grass will grow back so you
can make your rounds but you still need
to be able to take up a sizable space
I'm trying to tell people you start in a
very small circle but find your pasture
memento mori by living life to the
fullest you are also ready to let go at
any moment to not meet death with fear
or anger or rather welcoming because
some things you just can't control will
meant amore remember that I like how you
said remember does but what I heard was
remember dead yeah I was kind of hoping
having metal water back into that yeah
[ __ ] remember that yeah memento mori
mother what's my name
Socrates remember that meant amore
philosophy Oh si f philosophy remember
that the idea of not letting things out
of your control change your behavior is
a simple practice that anyone can
immediately grasp but it's much much
harder to act upon achieving virtue is
not easy however the length the Stoics
went with this idea is often heavily
criticized misunderstood and dismissed
as being cold an epithet ik it's funny
because I get called that sometimes with
some of the girls I've dated where they
feel like because I'm not angry or upset
in a situation I don't care saying I'm
like no I
still present and I'm not behaving this
way because I do care and I think this
is the most pragmatic way to go about
this I understand that you've messed up
and you're trying to make amends the
best way we can do that is to talk
calmly and get her points across rather
than yelling or me being angry at you so
you can get some kind of emotional
response makes more sense for me to talk
to you and really understand now how we
got here so we don't have to go there
again let's rationalize about what's
going on hmm you know I mean but yes it
does make you look like you don't care
because there's no emotion that coming
out of you yeah women like when you look
like you feel stuff right it's not so
much that women want you to be bothered
right they don't want you to be pissed
off right but it's their barometer to
know on what scale you are the problem
is when you throw it when you have
thoughts ISM it doesn't show that
because you're trying to rationalize
maybe I'm gonna use that to be pissed
off or if you push me there i'ma show
you is that what you wanna see right
it's ugly right it's ugly and it doesn't
resolve anything right we're just too
much
shouting can we go back to the words I
know I agree in every match that I've
seen yelling never solve anything here's
an example xenophobe when told about the
death of his child responded simply and
calmly with I knew my son was immortal
you can take the extreme of this quote
in any way you want but the reality of
the lesson is to simply not fight
against nature and let it consume you
focus on what you can control and let it
be your virtue Marcus Aurelius who is
known as one of the five good Roman
emperors did not live an easy life he
dealt with chronic pain and his ruling
as Emperor would be fought against to
practice self-control every morning
Marcus would meditate it would meditate
over all the bad horrible things and
people that would oppose him that day
here's a quote from his meditations when
you wake up in the morning tell yourself
the people I deal with today will be
meddling ungrateful arrogant dishonest
jealous and surly they are like this
because they can't tell good from evil
but I have seen the beauty of good and
the ugliness of evil and have recognized
that the wrongdoer has a nature related
to my own not of the same blood and
birth but the same mind and possessing a
share of
Devine and so none of them can hurt me
no one can implicate me in ugliness nor
can I feel angry at my relative or hate
him we were born to work together like
thief hands and eyes like the two rows
of teeth upper and lower to obstruct
each other is unnatural to feel anger at
someone to turn your back on him these
are unnatural is the idea that
regardless of how much someone hates you
you don't have to engage the idea of
hating them back because it doesn't do
you any good and it doesn't do them any
good what you get cut them off you sure
sure yeah
or will you distancing yourself from
them is not the same as you impeding
them yeah it's like tiger's eye I have
some people who hate me if they're
trying to reach level success I'm not
gonna get in the way to stop them all in
fact I might even encourage them to try
to mend those fences put that so that's
an optional thing but it's that idea
that it doesn't do you or them or
anybody any good to get in their way
again to normal people it makes you look
like you don't care because your
reactions and one day feels like okay
you gonna be like that I cut that off
yeah and you go go back to business then
is this okay they just cut me off mmm
you've not even pissed off or anything
yeah it's like you being emotional is
the barometer of people knowing where
you at if you don't even show that they
think you don't care they'll link that
that they don't care always that despite
CBT deriving from stoicism as previously
mentioned stoicism itself doesn't talk
much about depression services some
focus rather more on anger they look at
anger as Marcus describes as ugly and
irrational if you imagine an angry face
it's rarely a pretty one however it's an
emotion that is often today displayed in
media when a character in a film for
example acts in revenge he's often seen
carrying out the same bad deed that was
originally done to him
but we still recognize his action as
somewhat Noble and satisfying we even
enjoy seeing anger if it's justified of
course I think anger and revenge as
always there's always gonna be some
element of satisfaction of like
asserting your power and being able to
one-up the person who did wrong to you
there's always going to be some element
of satisfaction doesn't mean that's a
virtuous thing or that's a positive
thing but it's natural for people to
think that it might be kind of good
because they feel kind of good
do you think what I'm saying I
understand but also I mean the revenge
part can be their meditation
they can't be meditation because it
doesn't take you to a serene or virtuous
place
you can't qualify everything as
meditation no you can't but I mean it
replaces it doesn't mean it's the same
thing but it replaces that action
nothing is the same thing what I what I
really mean to say is that some people
instead of meditating and being like
let's say lashing out or whatever or
negative writing it down they're gonna
use that energy and they're gonna
transfer that energy into revenge it
doesn't make it virtuous if it doesn't
do the same thing as meditation but the
people that do that it brings them a
certain form of satisfaction
satisfaction is not meditation nobody
brings me to a level we're gonna be at
ease with yourself right wait when you
write it down when you air it out when
you put it down where you put it out
there it has been said so it's like you
feel like there's something that you did
about that emotion whereas when you
revenge I think it's a bit of the same
energy that you had but you transfer it
into revenge it doesn't make it very
truth doesn't make anything like that
but it's like a transfer in their energy
he turned into something else you could
use that energy that's bottled up that
you need to meditate you could turn it
into a negative or a positive right the
negative would be revenge or lashing out
on the person or the other side of it
would be to meditate about it or just
writing it down and all that doing that
sources and stuff but you did eliminate
that energy you just transferred it yes
you transferred I'm not saying you
animated and you keep a little bit with
you you never let go fit mmm right so
it's not can be a substitute for if it
doesn't accomplish the same goal I
believe it can achieve the same goal but
revenge can lead to some form of
emptiness yeah okay if you think so
Marcus however received the word one day
that his close friend in general Ovidius
kasia's had betrayed in Casius had found
out a rumor that Marcus was close to
death and possibly even dead and so
Casius took this as an opportunity to
declare himself as a new Caesar a
betrayal of this magnitude would enrage
and upset anyone if it happened to us
but well Marcus did especially for the
time being was astounding he did nothing
he didn't want to cause panic among
people if the word got out of the
betrayal and confusing of ruling he
instead acted rationally without anger
and without hatred and made the
announcement that he will march against
Casius not to kill him but to capture
him when a friend betrays us we have
every right to get angry but markers
control this anger even mentioned that
he hoped Cassio's would not kill himself
in shame before his arrival for Marcus
coming would be a great testimony of his
virtue
Marcus managed to not just calm himself
but his people and while doing so he did
what needed to be done which was to
secure the Empire and he succeeded plate
though long before him said that
philosophers should be Kings this act of
Marcus was a true testimony to that
statement a famous story quote once said
it is not possible to live well today
unless you treat it as your last death
is always near and stoicism markers
meditated heavily on this theme as well
it might seem morbid but it helps remind
oneself to live in the moment it helps
you build virtue build character and
prepare yourself to be ready to depart
at any moment Marcus would meditate
every evening to remind himself to be
grateful for every day to me this is the
most powerful part of Stoicism it's
called memento mori remember that you
might have heard before all right well
that was it for today's video it's good
good yeah i jus didn't know there was a
name for it yeah when those guys in
doing no gaming also I'm not familiar
with this catalogue so you may have a
whole bunch of other videos like this
and I don't know about I've got I've
never really had much of a perception of
PewDiePie but I really enjoyed this
video this is really dope I hope he does
more stuff like these I know these are
really cool things yeah
but he's right that's right I didn't
know that was a name on it I was just
calling it being rational yeah and when
you're storing like that people think
that also you are- know it's not being
rational you wanna know why because
rational doesn't necessarily have to do
with virtue virtue is a sort of like
you're talking about ethics and your
coats to live by you do what I'm saying
rational is just about what is the most
logical next step but it doesn't
necessarily mean that you're gonna be
virtuous because you're logical
there are plenty of people who are evil
who are rational and rational
that's correct I felt like the part
about the Greeks and its history was
super insightful for me because I didn't
know what went that far back so it was a
cool little history lesson
two things I want to bring up to you in
light of this video do you think about
death
funny that you said that because I was
thinking about that when he was talking
and that was a discussion with me my
girl at some point she saw the way I was
reacting to death she's like what is
wrong with you right again I look like I
didn't care it's not so much that I
didn't care it's just that I was
laughing when he said that yeah I know
my son was immortal I had to deal with
death unjust death that I believe that
it was when I was a kid really young so
and at some point it was like happening
like every month and I was like there
was much and the way to protect myself
was just to whenever I meet someone or
someone is new or is that yeah I meet
that person that person is going to die
instead so the first time that she we
met the first time I went out together
you you you said you said you said that
yeah I was like you it's fun we have now
but at some point you're gonna die at
some point you're not gonna be there at
some point all this is gonna be gone
right whether because we're not gonna be
together or because you're actually
gonna be going away I'm gonna be gone
whatever you're gonna leave my life
right so and that's for everybody's when
I was a teen I started imagining
everybody being their mom like them my
sister all my relative everybody so I
kind of got okay with that the turning
point for that was when I was in first
year of high school one of my friends
she died a tragic moment and I said like
yo I gotta get used to it because if I
don't prepare myself to that it's gonna
be too much I have to prepare myself or
else this life is gonna be really hard
cuz that's just a reality everybody I
know is gonna leave so up to now I've
been good with this and I've been good
with sickness as well I mean this is the
people around me that don't really take
it well well because they see the way my
mom my mom which was sick she was like
yo you don't look like you cared like yo
it's either we're gonna go through this
or we're not let's just let's just make
sure that everything is done right so
that you do so yeah the death thing
I'm kind of okay with it it's part of
life yeah they said that was my waited
to protect myself hmm yeah I like that
well that's it for today the only
question that you yeah let's ask you
want to get to wow did you deal with it
I don't know yet so we'll probably talk
about that another time okay but that's
it for today's video we want to hear
your thoughts let us know in the
comments below
[Music]